[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone i'm lou studdard producer
at toys for bob and i'm here to talk to
you about crash bandicoot 4.
it's about time crash 4 is a direct
sequel to crash bandicoot warped
the devious villains neocortex and dr
entropy have finally escaped
their interdimensional prison leaving an
evil scientist-sized hole in the
universe
now they've got their eyes set on not
only simply conquering this dimension
but all dimensions and it's up to crash
and coco to save the day
crash bandicoot 4 is about time as the
first totally new game in the crash
bandicoot series in over a decade
so for us at toys for bob we felt that
it was important to reintroduce
long-time fans as well as new players to
this amazing franchise
[Music]
first we made sure to incorporate the
classic tense precise and perspective
shifting platforming that we all fell in
love with
and then we wanted to introduce exciting
new elements that we can't wait to show
you today
let's start with insanity beach this is
where crash's adventure first
started and where we picked things up
again and crash for but there have
definitely been changes since we first
saw insanity beach all those years ago
and throughout crash 4 you'll see those
changes to our game play
and even our art style our art teams
wanted to take inspiration
from not just the original games but the
animated cartoons that inspired
those original games all while also
delivering bigger more awe-inspiring
dimensions to explore
throughout crash 4 you'll see wide open
new vistas
new character models and lots of
expressive animations
and with all of that also comes new
additions to the platforming
like having the ability to wall run rope
swing rail grind and zipline as well
in the original trilogy specifically
crash warped there were certain moments
in the game where crash would change
outfits think crash wearing a biker
jacket when riding a motorcycle
that seemed like a natural area for us
to expand upon
so we have loaded the game with tons of
awesome skins that you can earn and wear
throughout the game
these skins are totally cosmetic and a
fun way to express yourself while
playing the game
and just to be clear there's no mtx here
skins are earned by completing different
challenges
and earning gems within levels crash 4
also introduces the quantum masks the
powerful protectors of time and space
crash and coco will need their
assistance throughout the game to tackle
the crazy challenges that we're going to
be throwing at the player
whether it's ika ika who gives you the
ability to instantly flip your center of
gravity at the press of a button
puna wahoo allows you to slow down the
world around you
or lonnie lowly who allows you to phase
shift elements in and out of existence
bending the rules of reality and
altering your environment with these new
masks is a must
we also can't wait to talk to you about
the fourth mask akano
but that's gonna have to wait for
another day what we can tell you today
though
is that crash isn't the only character
you get to take control of during this
adventure for starters
you can play the entire game as coco any
level that you can play as crash you can
also play as coco
it was also very important for us that
she take a more prominent role in the
story this time as well
but that's not all we've got a few other
characters that you'll get to control at
key points in the adventure
so that they can provide their own fresh
perspectives and new gameplay
here you can see that you'll be taking
control of neocortex he's all about
using his blaster to
change an enemy in his path in addition
to playing his cortex we're excited to
reveal that for the first time
you'll also get to tail slap your way
through crates's dingo dial
i repeat you get to play as dingo dial
in crash four
and a lot has changed in the year since
we landed go dial in fact
he hung up his old flamethrower rocket
launcher combo when he decided to retire
from a life a villain
and open a diner unfortunately for dingo
fortunately for us
his adventure begins by witnessing the
destruction of said beloved diner
and getting sucked into another
dimension
finally there's one more surprise i'm
incredibly excited to show you today
the crash bandicoot series has always
been about finding new and exciting ways
to play through the game
in the past it's been about taking on
time trials or discovering all the
hidden secrets
well for crash four we wanted to bring
something brand new to the table so we
teamed up with our friends at bnox to
create a brand new style of play for
crash 4
that we call inverted mode it's our
souped-up
bump-a-berry fueled take on a mirror
mode not only are perspective shifted
but now each of the dimensions are
rendered in a new and unique art style
that really changes the look and feel of
the experience
one dimension could be asking you to
traverse through a neon wasteland
while another tasks players with
spinning paint all over the environment
to see their path forward
we've even got one that feels like an
old-timey movie with the overcranked
camera speed increasing the actual speed
of gameplay as well
once unlocked players can replay all the
game's levels with a totally new
and dynamic look and feel it's an
incredibly fun feature that is going to
give every player
especially the completionists out there
a reason to revisit each level again
to see what new and exciting experiences
in store for them
[Applause]
so that's some of the new stuff that we
have in store for you in crash bandicoot
4
it's about time experience the space and
time bending madness on october 2nd
today's state of play is loaded with
third party updates for ps4 and psvr
and some new ps5 gameplay too
we open the show with an all new look at
crash four it's about time
coming to playstation 4 on october 2nd
now let's keep the party going with the
latest from io interactive
[Music]
besides this is your big day you should
mingle
have fun oh don't worry about that my
art
speaks for itself well i have to go you
want me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are happy to announce braid
anniversary edition
it's the classic puzzle adventure where
you manipulate time
hand repainted for modern high
resolutions many areas have been
re-envisioned to make them more unique
and it's even more like a living
painting with brush strokes animating
the world
there are more than nine pixels for each
pixel in the original game
there are new animations for smoother
motion improved sound and music to
enhance the mood
and many hours of developer commentary
and interviews
on subjects like puzzle design
programming and visual art
we plan to make it the most detailed
commentary in any game
ever so if you want to learn how video
games are made braid anniversary edition
will be a really good resource
we hope you'll enjoy the game when it
comes out early next year
[Music]
the pathless is a mythic adventure set
on a mystical island
let's take a quick tour in this new
footage captured from ps5
[Music]
hi everyone this is matt nava from giant
squid
i'm excited to share more with you today
about our upcoming game the pathless
[Music]
the pathless is an open world mythic
adventure game set in a vast forest
you play as the hunter
the hunter is a master of archery she
can shoot talismans to fill her dash
meter which allows her to bound across
the landscape
fluid dynamic movement is at the core of
the pathless
so the game's unique take on archery is
all about timing
not aiming down sights this design was
critical
to making it possible to shoot even
while moving fast and performing
acrobatic maneuvers
you instantly feel as skilled as the
hunter herself
[Music]
with help from the eagle you can even
fly
the bond between the hunter and the
eagle is central in the pathless
[Music]
you can gain altitude while you glide by
[Music]
flapping
[Music]
make sure you pet the eagle to keep it
clean and in good flying condition
[Music]
you'll find secrets all over the island
if you know where to look
[Music]
collecting crystals will let you upgrade
the eagle's ability to flap
you will also discover larger puzzles to
solve in ancient structures
[Music]
huh pathless is all about finding your
own way forward
so unlike most open world games there's
no map
instead the hunter can use her mask to
peer into the spirit world
and discover distant landmarks it even
shows you where you've been
getting to higher vantage points will
let you see further with spirit vision
[Music]
giant cursed spirits the source of the
darkness will pose a constant threat to
you on your quest
they will try to separate you from the
eagle
stay still in the light to avoid
detection
you won't be able to take on the cursed
spirits until you've returned light to
the obelisks
[Music]
when the obelisks are restored the
cursed spirits will be vulnerable
chase them down through the forest to
corner them in a dramatic final battle
huh
[Music]
the hunter and eagle will have to defeat
the cursed spirits to bring light back
to the world
i hope you've enjoyed this overview of
the pathless
we've only scratched the surface there's
so much more to explore
and discover the pathos is coming out
later this year thanks for watching
[Music]
next up let's see what's in store for
spelunky 2.
hi my name is derek you and i'm the
creator of spelunky
for spelunky 2 i wanted to make sure we
made something that got old fans excited
and also brought in new players
it was important we didn't change the
things that made spelunky such a unique
experience in the first place
so many people became fans of the game
through their friends and family
and even strangers on the internet
that's one reason why we're adding
online multiplayer
so that more people can play the game
together
and i also wanted to include that
feeling of community into sponky 2
itself to make sure that the game felt
welcoming even though it's difficult
in splonky 2 when you do runs and
discover new characters you'll also be
building an in-game community
and family i designed the world of
spelunky 2 to feel much more rich and
dynamic than spelunky 1.
it's gonna feel a lot more full players
will be able to explore and
interact with it in lots of new ways
for example you'll be able to ride
turkeys
and find hidden passageways
and you'll have to choose between
branching paths as you make your way
deeper into the caves
as a result the stories players create
will have much more texture to them even
after many many hours of playing i still
have interesting runs that don't even go
past the first area
in spelunky one runs often centered
around the shops
and how you chose to interact with them
so in sponky 2 we've expanded the
shopping experience and made them more
nuanced
and exciting and also added new
characters that can help you
or hinder you given how amazing the
sponky community is
it's hard to say how long it will take
to find the deepest secrets
but i think the great thing about
spelunky is that the deepest secrets are
the ones that even i don't know about
and there are lots of new things to play
with that i hope players can use to push
past the boundaries of what we as the
developers know about the game
i have two types of favorite stories
from spelunky fans
first are when people are genuinely
surprised by something that happened
in the game and second the ones where
people shared a fun experience with
friends and family in multiplayer
these are the stories i wanted to expand
upon in spelunky
they're really what guided my design
choices
after releasing spelunky i knew there
was a lot more that could be done with
the concept in the world
knowing that possibility was out there
is what's been exciting for me and the
rest of the team
in a lot of ways when spelunky 2 comes
out i want players to experience what we
experienced
making it that feeling that there's
something special there waiting for you
to discover it
a big thanks to the fans who've waited
patiently for us to finish spawning two
it's been a long journey but i think
it's gonna be worth it
thanks
[Music]
one
we've got a bunch of new ps4 updates to
share with you starting with a closer
look at
genshin impact
hey there's something strange over there
come on let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
cool
[Music]
i deal in death if you cannot bring
yourself to kill
speak my name
what is this disturbance to which
i awaken
huh think you can get away
time for takeoff
[Music]
gods have squealed for my mercers
who are you to stand in the way of my
[Music]
vengeance
this ambition of yours what a waste of
stardust
go all out or go home
i am
i'm not done yet
you should have remained dead
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to talk bug snacks let's check
out some gameplay footage captured from
ps5
my invitation is open come
join me on the island
wow that's your new lead another
monster hunt elizabeth megafig is a
two-bit con artist
don't tell me you actually believe this
half-baked nonsense
i swear if you chase this bug snack
story you're out of a job
you're the journalist desperate said
you'd be coming
there's a bug snack right over there do
me a favor and take my snack trap
stranger i could use your help this
bunker goes wild for ketchup
use it to lead the bunker over yonder
i want you to use that journalistic
instinct to find out what my
favorite bug snack is and feed it to me
ops how's my little sprout doing he
misses papa
oh of course he does well i have a few
prototype traps that i could put to use
you're pretty good at stuff and nobody
hates you yet
you can catch bug snacks and bring
everybody back to slacksburg
well say you do find these bug snacks
and make it back alive
you just might keep your job now get
going and try not to fall off a cliff
[Music]
there's a lot more in store let's start
with an update on an eagerly awaited
playstation vr game
[Music]
i don't understand why you never
mentioned that you had the
force
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whatever you do stay in the light
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
now let's take a look at two new games
headed to ps5
we are the forest shadows
ghosts running silently between the
straight
coal lines of a corrupt state
they count
authority
bypass defenses and strike at the heart
[Music]
and the people call us heroes
from the day of i
to others we are rivals
[Music]
we are all outlaws
but some of us will become
legends
from the day
[Music]
[Music]
fish
[Music]
before we wrap up let's take a tour of
godfall
we've got new ps5 gameplay for this
melee focused action
epic launching this holiday
[Music]
hello my name is keith lee and i am the
game director
for godfall on behalf of counter play
games
we are very excited to share gameplay
with you today and to offer you a
glimpse
into the mystical world of godfall
today you'll be seeing extensive
gameplay captured on a playstation 5
development kit
please keep in mind that the game is
still a work in progress
and some things may change from the
final product as we continue to learn
and harness the power of sony's next
generation console
please enjoy
so let's jump right into what godfall is
godfall is a looter slasher that
features intense action
satisfying moment-to-moment combat and
robust
loot progression systems you can enjoy
the game at your own pace
playing alone or through online co-op
with up to two
additional teammates godball is set in a
brand new
high fantasy universe filled with heroic
nights
arcane magic and forbidden realms
the world is split up into the elemental
realms of
earth water
air and fire godfall
is a complete package all loot and gear
in the game
are acquired or unlocked through
gameplay
there are no micro transactions no
waiting for content
it's all in the game on day one
as you adventure you'll get to tear
through enemies to challenge a mad god
who awaits you at the top
you play a valorian knight a god-like
warrior
able to equip valor plates legendary
armor sets that transform you
into an unstoppable master of melee
combat
throughout your journey you'll find
ancient valor plates
lost in time each with their own
characteristics and long history
now let's talk about game play and
godfall
first our team wanted to do something
different
we wanted to combine action rpg loot
progression with third-person melee
combat to create
what we think is a looter slasher
our game is therefore one part gear
driven and
one part player skill driven in other
words
not only do we want you to find
exquisite weapons with
powerful loot rates but we also want you
to have that feeling of accomplishment
or mastering the wide set of combat
mechanics available to you
in godfall from a combat philosophy
perspective the melee combat godfall is
intended to be fluid
dynamic and interactive embracing
offense
over defense more often than not you'll
be facing multiple enemies
at the same time as a result you should
always
be moving and closing the gap on enemies
also you dominate the combat space not
the enemies
and the game rewards you for being
aggressive
now that you're familiar with the combat
philosophy let's dig into the weapons
themselves
in godfall there are five weapon classes
the long
sword
the dual blades
the pole arm
the two-handed warhammer
and the two-handed green sword
each weapon class has their own unique
move sets and play styles
ranging from fast combos to more
strategic deliberate play
as you defeat enemies in your adventures
you will acquire
numerous weapons for each weapon
category
each weapon with their own primary and
secondary
traits at a later date we will delve
into the weapon classes
and how to modify them in greater detail
for now
we'll go over the dual blades and the
long sword
weapon classes the dual blades are the
fastest weapon class in godfall
embodying speed fluidity and mobility
the dual blades are exceptional against
soft unarmored targets or single targets
you can perform a combo by executing
four consecutive light attacks
the dual blades heavy attack is a
spinning blade cyclone
the blade cyclone can also be used as a
finisher
at the end of your light attack combo so
what are the signature moves for the
dual blades
as you build up charge you can also
activate inner focus
which is unique to the dual blades which
inflicts massive damage
in a short period of time there's also a
mortal coil
where you can throw your blade into an
enemy pulling the enemy towards you like
pulling a cable
now let's switch to the longsword weapon
class
long swords are balanced weapons
embodying crisp
damage and simple cooldowns without
needing a lot of elaborate combo
setups similar to dual blades
long swords have their own four hit
light attack combo
then there's the heavy attack finisher
which can be used at the end of your
light attack combo
there are three signature moves for the
longsword class
there's spectral flurry which cannot be
interrupted and deals high damage to
multiple nearby targets
then there's spiral technique which
eviscerates all enemies
in a straight fixed path notice there's
a white flash
after a long sword swing called a timing
attack if you press the shield button
exactly at the same time you'll perform
a devastating shield uppercut with your
longsword
the shield is a core part of godfall
it's available to you throughout the
entire game
you can always block incoming attacks
with your shield
if you press the shield button at the
right time you can also
parry an attack you can perform a light
attack
after a last second shield block to
counter attack with a powerful
shield strike a shield is great not just
for defense
but also offense you can aim and throw
your shield
which will hit multiple nearby targets
if you tap the shield button
just as you catch your shield you can
perform a powerful wave attack
you can double tap the shield button to
petrify enemies
[Music]
and of course you can perform an r3
ground finisher on
enemies that were knocked down to the
ground
[Music]
ugh
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed our first
walkthrough video of godfall running on
the playstation 5.
we also want to thank all the fans for
their endless support since our initial
reveal back in december
we have a few more surprises coming down
the road such as details on loot
and progression and are eager to share
more with you on our way to launch this
holiday season
we hope that you will join our godfather
community on twitter
facebook and youtube thank you
[Music]
[Music]
that's a wrap we hope you enjoyed this
peek into the future of playstation
see you next time
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
2
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
out
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you